how school resumes back welcome back to
first light this game is really pink my
headphones my controller my dildo it's
all good let's do with you I was bored
like I wanted to play but I didn't want
to record I didn't wanna like talk and
that's a thing yep they're youtuber
problems right there but I spend like a
lot of time collecting these neon lumens
that's what they're called I guess
they're like spread out I can't show you
one now cuz I freaking collect all of
them I got like cooler powers now like
look I can do that and then I can do
that twice how cool is that you have no
idea what I'm talking about it well
that's probably my problem yeah you're
right okay well looking for this drone
it's right by the other UI
yeah gachy now mr. drone oh that's what
Dalton used to say wait there's a second
one come on my friend enjoying a good
weather would you be interested in
joining my sniper Klein no wow that got
a bird a late reaction also you don't
get [ __ ] for [ __ ] with civilians in
in this game like you did in the first
one by the road somewhere
let's see yeah the hair so if we get
hack in to actually see what it sees
shouldn't we be able to hack to destroy
itself
no it's above where is it is that us
there is it [ __ ] with us
huh there you are following you [ __ ]
slo-mo shot whoa gotcha one more so I
just want to point out that we just got
betrayed by this other guy and then this
random girl calls us and we do exactly
what she says this tells us to do as
well like fetch you are a dog literally
like a dog like ow I've seen you in yoga
pants alright that way I can see myself
don't [ __ ] with me drone Oh whoopsie
that's actually pretty cool
whoa but I shut it down or just got it
okay we better get category defeat the
ambush I got a good shot at oh hi Piper
Oh guys guys guys guys guys guys I know
you're from Seattle and I know you're
weird but brofist what does that do ah
let's keep using that or tickle he's
back there you go he liked it as another
one oh a lot about where to go and I'm
already there she really has a boner for
this Brent guy surveillance blackout
thank you very much a necessary
prolonging text obtained play like yeah
we need the game three five minutes
longer add a text every once in a while
how about here that'd be great
hello gentlemen you don't see me do you
well I have to subdue you to join my
sniper client hey you go join it learn
to be MLG can't you see there we go
here we'll all join my sniper time
because you're all [ __ ] that's the
problem only recruit [ __ ] in my
sniper got freaking fast we are now just
look at it why aren't you looking stop
picking your nose god
have some respect I'm here too you know
are you worried oh I'm sorry I didn't
see it looks like you were picking your
nose okay
once you start cracking open you got
maybe a few minutes before Shane finds
out I'll have to move fast
well what did I do where did I do it
right do it right do it wrong I'm
wearing nothing but a thong hello
gentlemen
did I do it right quickly defeat the
guards they don't even know I'm here
are they deaf oh sorry it's legs there
we go
teleport to teleport girls there we go
hello-o it's neither I don't see here
hurry to the Oh God I gotta go fast and
we fix it yes [ __ ]
away something like that sorry I gotta
go fast excuse me
faster so I gained time from going
through those do you see it like if we
made it with plenty of time look at a
for that girl you're a boy huh you don't
know yet you might change your mind I'm
just saying it's not too late
wink wink all right hello oh well why
not
oh is that quickly defeat the gods which
guards call these guys guards ha well
that was hard it's quite impressive mess
assorted in the exact same way as the
other container
plus they have my favorite magazine
white women now wait what oh [ __ ] I had
got a hurry sorry sorry why don't you
tell me what's going there Big O easy
peasy hello cops whoa cops calm down I'm
on your side
hey Einstein I'm on your side no sorry I
have to say it every time that's the
thing I have are they fault Jesus what
are they doing calm down cops they're
cray-cray and not like crayons I tried
so hard over that one I've been saving
that one for months literally stop it
caps you don't know that could be a bro
or a ho
wink wink okay here we are where's the
cut there you go hello there hope you
don't mind me sharing this container no
you do well that's just too bad
alright or the other cop out of the out
of the guards again yeah there yeah
there's doing such a good job amazing
oh he's a weak spot as his face you must
look like Oprah or some [ __ ] hey come
here don't make me smack a [ __ ]
good night a good kick has never hurt
anyone except when they die oh there was
a timer again come on I don't even see
it we really need to get these aah hey
oh god they smoke the smoke I'm not
Smurfs as anymore oh god what am I
supposed to do when one cannot be
samosas one will have to be gnosis
that's what my mom told me ultra brofist
of justice you guys like that yeah you
like that you like staring at the
container you know what I like to stare
at your ass it's so legit lucious I
learned a new word today okay that you
don't just die marvelous
all right let's happened let me guess
nothing whoa what a big surprise
you wanna high-five finally oh well
thanks for telling me I have single
arity now I might be oh my god I'm so
sad that she died because she was such
an essential character for me I really
felt really deeply invested emotionally
in her character because because reasons
come on we got to listen to that douche
again how is that gonna work just leave
town did what he said he was like leave
town and I would be alright all the time
that's what I would do but I'm not Brent
and I don't have an amazing mohawk so
what do I know about look at this I'm
flying like a fricken mohawk is that a
thing is that a bird or do they just
make that up to describe the haircut one
cannot be sure these days but do look at
my speed man it is the sweetest speed of
all time if sanic was here he would make
out my me assists Shane in reinforcing
his hold on Seattle I don't want to all
right fine
hello
don't distract it get out your phone but
you cops
I'm not gonna kill all those dudes just
so you can have a sit down I'll distract
them it's not making a ruckus so they'll
have to peel off and investigate my
where we're supposed to go break havoc
in the city we just need to do something
crazy to distract them how is this not
crazy I'm saying him let's cut but this
city doesn't even care if you sound
other cars how am I supposed to how am I
supposed to write taxi you're dead Oh
whoa hello whoa sorry you can do these
dates
oh you need is in lower firepower oh I
made a little bouncy do it again there
you go oh there's a bar ow there's a bar
showing my destruction
but I would never hurt anyone all right
let's kill some people night
all right let's let's mess with some
people oh nice mark I said a double
latte [ __ ] oops you dropped your latte
aren't you gonna pick it up oh my god
you look so fat ha I look way better in
yoga pants what about you you're making
out with a chair that's illegal
that's right ain't nobody [ __ ] with the
monkey I mean me what else are we gonna
do that's a nice car there would be a
shame if anything happened to it that it
there you go
you'll shout hey car do you wanna
brofist guess not I swear this was the
Irish pub they had two of them Willy in
one city can't accept dad go faster nice
ass let me smack it there you go you're
welcome
there's a heart mr. shoulder hurt now
oh you're poor thing you don't even look
like you're slightly in pain that is
actually kind of [ __ ] disturbing oh
my god Kelly tell it now what is wrong
with you human shooter Ted there we go
oh god she's still doing it oh god let's
get out of there
brofist that but see he doesn't even
care if she broke his butt look at this
brofist that bite look at that he has an
iron ass
it's called a Nidoran s it's come from
the reign at Renaissance let's push this
guy into the water come on go oh hello
he divided by zero that's what happens
are you what are you going take a dive
have fun
oh no he drowned huh oh my god I'm so
happy I'm raisin
with my neon gas coming from my ass I
like to listen to jazz when nobody is
looking at me don't look at me nobody ah
should be done
this is explode a few macaws he has a
laser gun that's amazing
oh he's talking about me isn't he can we
grab it yeah
she's really bad at negotiating fend off
the police fend up the police fend off
the police or that's the lyrics right
that's what I skip said it little did me
they're bad murdering cops but hey what
are you gonna do about it there's a
sniper there you are hello sniper how
are you today there's a sandwich it's
made out of laser and death oh you know
what so far running down this alleyway
has not worked well for these guys so
finally have all the cops looks kind of
identical maybe it's like a like I was
fashion trend going on where they all
have the same haircut and face and
everything there you go
they're all dead - then a lot of
similarities here Jesus calm down caps
they all dead now oh that's fantastic
let me see those yoga pants what why
would I
yoga pants yoga pants has the best
beatbox
I have ever had in my entire life should
be in here
come on start to freak out I'd focus on
Brent's it was the only thing that calm
me down slow into a good memory
she really won that brendi huh knew that
if we didn't leave town I was never
gonna get clean started taking risks to
make money
wanted to buy a Bolton's meeting the
Canada yeah that's what people do
I told him it sounded crazy when he came
home missing a few teeth i shaped up
tried going cold turkey
he stayed by me through all this [ __ ] I
owe him he's my brother
love it girl who's gonna stop me
our Empress I gotta end our episode
there but I hope you bros enjoyed
watching anyway it's in this great this
is still not a dildo even though I'm
holding it like one yeah leave a like if
you enjoyed watching and I'll see you
tomorrow
well finished